I kind of feel like I was meant to be
blind just able to see things from a
completely different point of view
it took some courage to these different
tools but when I'm working a piece of
wood it feels very peaceful it's got
such a fluid feel to it that it's almost
like another dog I can feel it flow and
change and then I turn it off announce
it beautiful ornate bold I grew up in a
small town in Colorado I felt like I
never really fit in a lot there
it really started making me feel
depressed so when I was 16 I attempted
suicide by shooting myself I didn't want
to face the world anymore the more I
think about it the older I get the less
it makes sense luckily I only lost my
sense of sight and smell and left my
mind totally intact
I learned woodworking about eight years
after I became blind I went to a
training center for blind people I
started going to that woodshop and
discovered I just had a knack for it you
know I'd never thought of woodworking
after I was blind but I come to learn
that there is actually a very large
community of blind woodworkers it was
just incredible for me it just opened up
my world
my wife Annie helps me in so many ways
she has been an enormous part of my
woodworking she helps me select
different colors of wood for one thing
but she's also the one that bought me my
lathe she supports me in every way and
just has been a wonderful part of my
life I mean out here in my woodshop
about six hours most days and can't tell
you how nice it is when I'm out here
covered in wood chips I start with my
rough piece of wood you know measure it
and see will this make a bowl or a
canister or a jewelry dish the best from
there I I turn on the design program in
my mind I call it my imagination is
still so visual you know cut it into a
usable block on the saw basically if you
follow the rules blind or sighted keep
my hands where they're supposed to be a
saw works like a saw and there's really
not much you can do about that and then
I mount it to the lathe and turn it into
a piece of art
I love the sounds it makes when you're
carving cuz different cuts will make
different sounds and then I'm really got
it going right and I'm making the
sweeping cut into a bowl it's just kind
of a hist it I feel the wood as it's
spinning with my left hand and I carved
with the right hand and I can feel it
transform under my fingers as I'm
cutting the wood away with the chisel I
can transform just a rough stump of wood
into a piece of art that looks like
wooden pottery
it's like you can feel the life in it it
just has this kind of magic to it it's
been one of the most fundamentally
life-changing things for me because I
have something I'm good at and it
produces something in the end